SPEAKER: Key Visualizer
is a visualization tool
that helps you analyze the
access patterns in your Cloud
Bigtable instance.
The Cloud Bigtable console lets
you monitor your application
with line charts, which is
effective in most cases.
However, how would you know
what is causing high CPU,
if there are any
hotspots or large rows,
or if a MapReduce is effecting
your serving latency?
That's why we are announcing Key
Visualizer for Cloud Bigtable.
It shows you read and write
patterns in two dimensions--
over time and across keyspace.
It helps you find
or prevent hotspots.
It helps you find rows
with too much data, which
can cause performance issues.
And you can see if your
key schema is balanced.
Key Visualizer has a heat map
that shows time horizontally.
In this example,
we see the number
of operations over one week.
The keyspace is
shown vertically.
A heat scale shows values
of a selected metric.
For example, ops-- from
cold, representing zero,
over blue, to purple,
to red, to yellow,
to glowing white for
very high values.
The tool tip will
show us details
about this metric for a
particular time and key range.
In this example, notice
that some key ranges,
like the one at the bottom,
exhibit a diurnal pattern,
whereas, other
ranges are very cold.
Also notice the
white glowing line
in the middle that shows
the busiest key range.
The diagonal lines
represent linear scans
possibly from a MapReduce job.
The bar chart at the
bottom shows average values
across all visible keys
in 15-minute intervals.
Similarly, the bar
chart on the right
shows the averages over
time per key range.
This peak, again,
shows our busiest key.
Bigtable developers often create
keys with a prefix hierarchy.
In this example,
we see keys that
are constructed with delimiters,
such as slashes or dashes.
Key Visualizer has a
heuristic that automatically
extracts the prefix tree from
your key schema, if available.
The key prefix hierarchy
is shown on the left side.
We can see that the
behavior of a table
often correlates with the key
prefixes, as in this example.
When we click on
a prefix, it will
zoom into the
corresponding key range.
We can also zoom and pan
by using the scroll wheel
or dragging.
Key Visualizer offers
you these 11 metrics.
Ops is the sum of read
and write operations.
The three warnings metrics--
read or write pressure
index and large rows--
can discover problem areas.
Then, we have read metrics,
write metrics, latency,
and the amount of data stored.
Key Visualizer automatically
analyzes the performance
of your Bigtable instance.
This may involve trillions
of metric values.
Not only does Key
Visualizer aggregate
all of these metric values to
visualize them in the browser,
it also performs a
detailed analysis
on your table's performance.
This produces the
following metrics--
read pressure, which is an
opaque function of read CPU,
read key length, which is the
number of read ops waiting
to be executed, and latency.
Write pressure is
a similar function
to detect bad performance for
writing and large rows, which
will flag any row that contains
more than 1 gigabyte of data.
The result, shown in this view,
lets us discover and prevent
hotspots.
Best of all, these computations
won't cause any performance
degradation on your table.
And all this is free.
Let's now see how we
made this easy for you.
Key Visualizer opens by
default with the ops metric.
This gives us an overview of
the activity in your table.
Then, you check if there are
any warnings at the top bar.
If there aren't,
that's good news.
Your table's performance
is, most likely, fine.
This example has three warnings.
One of them is
severe, as indicated
by the three exclamation marks.
Clicking on the Read
Pressure Index warning
brings us to the
Read Pressure metric,
where we see immediately where
and when the problem happened.
We now zoom into the
white glowing stripe.
The tool tip shows us which
keys are causing problems.
At the top, we see
the worst problem.
It's a single key
that has been stressed
for more than three hours.
We can see the precise
name of the offending key.
We can see that it was using
nearly 600 million nodes
worth of CPU, which is more
than half of a server's CPU.
And it tells us what caused
this bad performance.
This row contains 9.22
gigabytes of data,
which is way more than
the recommended 256
megabytes per row.
In all of these
examples, we were looking
at one metric at a time.
Very often, however, we want
to compare different metrics.
Rather than switching
between metrics,
we can show all the
metrics and their values
together, on the right.
When we expand these, we
can see all these metrics
in miniature views.
The zoom and pan operations
are synchronized,
so we could compare
details for each symmetric.
Key Visualizer
for Cloud Bigtable
visualizes the key
access patterns
in your table, helps you find
hotspots, and large rows.
It extracts the key prefix
hierarchy, if available.
Key Visualizer analyzes
trillions of metric values
to point you to problem areas.
And it does this without any
impact on your Cloud Bigtable
performance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]